[Music]
welcome back to another episode of dirty
RT this is chapter 15 Jake we're gonna
do things a lot differently this time
because we're doing it we're going into
the online and we're gonna make what we
think is a representation of dirty RT
it's gonna be interesting I even have a
mic here so hopefully we can talk to
some some of the fine men and women
online the kind souls in the online
world this should be real real fun we're
gonna I mean the intro to the online
takes a while so we'll see if we get at
least get to the open world and then
maybe we'll call it I mean it's it I
think it takes like an hour or so yeah
it's kind of long but we'll probably
spend a lot of time on the character
creator because you go to make oh yeah
we want to make sure we really nail this
look yeah and as someone someone pointed
out last week like we're now so deep
into dirty already lore that there are
multiple timelines going on yeah there's
the Pigman timeline there's naked
already timeline there's there's catman
catman timeline there's 30 argue time on
yeah okay well so so here's the thing
right is like how close we want to get
to Arthur more again or do we just want
to go off the deep end like you know
what I mean like do ya just make Arthur
Morgan I say maybe we start with like
something that kind of looks like Arthur
Morgan and then from there we go deeper
and yeah okay maybe maybe we consider
Artie like this is like old dirty Artie
whoa all right big for sure
brawny are heavy I think heavy obviously
brawny but yeah heavy maybe heavy is
better
just yet just a gigantic nose that's me
hooked just pretty good oh that's pretty
funny yeah that look that look back so
we'll get rid of the facial hair for ya
there we needed to see his face yeah
that's good and then oh god you can get
like one tooth I'm pretty sure the
Gummer the Gummer the yokel yeah I mean
at its core core dirty already like
you'd like like that's we have to think
of it it's like if we had the ability to
like see the end game of dirty arty like
this is what we need to be thinking
about okay like if 30 RT was 60 cuz
that's the instead of right like all the
dials cranked up on the dirty arty book
wow that yeah
like that by now so imagine that with a
fat beard right like we I don't know
though this was a fabulously good maybe
great it's like we like the beard is the
one youthful part about him oh yeah just
jet-black
lifestyle well he's on the verge of
dying this is this is the last like
icing on the cake this is good that's
like the look if you like passed out in
the Sun so much sure is this like which
is something he does often just fried
moles sure what color is Eve green eyes
I didn't know there was more in here
alright I hate that no give me back that
that bridge grimace
okay is you can turn on the clarity so
just sounds like air donkey shows up I
want to turn them all down but I guess I
can I have to assign points I think
stamina should be the one turned all the
way down I'm real happy see those those
paws of yours yeah I feel bad for those
other prisoners cooped up in that little
space so like online RT is definitely a
sequel to dirty RT because he gets
thrown in jail for everything he's done
yeah this is like 30 years later so he's
got no idea what's happening yes he's
been in jail for 30 yo so forgot how to
talk while in jail make the downside
with making such a horrible looking
character is that people are gonna shoot
us on sight
[Laughter]
the pig man are you the vigilante send
me holy please show our guests to their
tent and give them some fresh clothes to
put on no thank you
you got easier like a raccoon hat is he
mumbling himself oh my god do you know
she's alright stupid he's got tied at
the ankles and water filled with mrs.
Leclerc husband was murdered no hair
tonic like her just got way more excited
there's food
how's it going okay I'll give him
sprinting through the woods barefoot
anyway that thick callus you guys see
those branches rustling way over there
oh gosh no how can we so I got this
what you gonna hear that oh man there's
so many things we need we need a
tomahawk I know sawed-off shotgun I
think that'll be the first thing we need
you know hey remember this cliff oh yeah
we won't get up get up
oh there we go all right you confirm
surviving the fall right here jump jump
for me come on jump I've been all up
cool hey how's it going good you alright
I just got out of jail been there for 30
years
what'd you get knocked in for killing
killing stealing killing stealing horses
even I've done it all on this man over
what do you name it
yeah I'm in a Ralph are you super fan
dude okay so we gonna shoot your hat off
I missed so when we get to the open
world I say we go out and we try to we
try to recruit people into our gang okay
try to start a gang and see how many
people you can get I think this is the
last mission and then I'm in the open I
think so too
yeah hey there we go well before 1054
cool 72 we're set oh yeah here oh excuse
me excuse me don't shoot don't shoot
don't shoot please scuse me I see you're
busy here do you want to join my you
want to join my gang excuse me this
season ago Mike you know don't shoot me
don't shoot me don't shoot me don't
shoot me don't shoot me don't shoot me
I'm I'm friendly okay trying to form a
posse you wanna drink doing a join mine
my posse
I'll find someone else to join my posse
I hate you anyway
[Laughter]
[Music]
hey there there you go don't you don't
you oh there you uh you wanna do my
policy kind of look like a hologram here
alright I could teach you two ways if
you join my posse
alright boss you up my friend we're
gonna take on all these [ __ ] hippie
there's a there's this guy his name's
vicious hey it's vicious
420 we're gonna go kill him and you're
gonna come with me we're gonna we're
gonna go kill his ass [ __ ] sorry my dude
hey hey fellas
it's me again just want to see if you
guys want join my posse oh oh
Adam Bango that's a mean shot you got
there Hey
here you want this body
hey where do you want this hey what hey
what you want
hey I'm just messing around man all
right all right
oh hey I got just disappear carry my
body around
[Music]
gloria hey i'm looking for looking for
people to join my my gang
ants lair you how do you how do you feel
about that you also also you like my
body you want this body oh you got one
yourself huh hey were you going amen
it's layer up sides add slayer that was
that man where you go sorry hey hold up
hold up hold up just a sec ma'am I'm
looking for a tough game do you want to
join my gang
my name is dirty arty what's yours oh
you wouldn't huh
I like that oh you're real good with
that rifle
you could be my gang I think that's just
fine where are you going could you hold
up just trying to catch up
oh sure I throw you in man my bad oh
yeah that's real nice you're good with
that knife how would you like to join my
gang you don't speak much do you when
you spiral your gun in the air once if
you want to join like where you going
I like your your horse's tail it's kind
of my style I don't have it quite yet
but I braved my own horse oh wow you
real you're real handy with that knife
you want to join my gang please I'm
begging you
oh my horse is pooping I'm we're not
getting a response here sorry I have to
do this you're coming with me now we're
gonna have to hog-tie you you if you
don't want to join my gang we're gonna
have to make you join my gang you're
coming with me my friend why don't we
give you a little dip oh oh oh yeah you
are rough damn that's a real badass
right there cuz someone's coming up here
on the bridge I like that who is this oh
there's a snake hey there
ah ants lair you sick son of a [ __ ] why
won't you just join our gang and flare
you got the stuff I could feel it I can
feel it
hey there sniper God's looking real fun
how would you like to join our gang huh
oh yeah you like shooting Gators don't
you well watch out there sir
sniper guys do you want to join our gang
give us give us a warning shot if you're
interested we'll send you a posse invite
maybe a can of beans yeah put that down
give us a sign here how do you you want
to join our gang ice kit you're skinning
both those can we help you
where do you want snapper guys where do
you want this here you he fell off
little comes in there huh that's fine
we'll still take you into the dirty arty
gang Oh what happened oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
look at that he'll try to kill that guys
it's a it's a fat bounty oh hell where's
our damn [ __ ] Oh
oh [ __ ] damn you shots in midair and now
it's time for show us your Artie's
hashtag show us your arty we got first
up lame-o Joe with a very awesome one
that he just memed I believe last
episode I found the right vest to
compliment my ass it's really great
thank you very much for that I like this
one a lot this is from I believe Oh
Audrey ik caiman this is awesome I also
like the nice little touch there
I know those squiggly lines you see the
stink the stink yeah this the scent is
palpable in this one it really is
radiating very awesome this is just this
is horrifying the black and white adds a
lot - yeah it really does it blends the
mask it's like the mask is fused into
Artie making him definitely pig man I
like this one because of just the
expression of already's face on the left
there it is a pretty important moment to
this camp and we have art Morgan yeah I
got the guy hogtied right there
horseback there is dirty looking horse
yeah I was loved loved the quote you
have fun I'm having fun they're already
dirty that is exactly terrifying imagine
living in that house and just walking
out and him next year or just walking
down a path and looking all the
scarecrow there and oh my god
this one was great this is a bunch of
photos they believe Wanda yeah ink it's
ink blot wolf there were multiple ones
but I picked this one because of the
lighting the lighting and how creepy it
looks it's probably the alien huh oh
yeah it looks like the alien Kevin and
some more fan art I saw sent me this
this is it's
g/b I guess her sister made it but
doesn't have a Twitter so she sent it to
me and yeah it's pretty fantastic its
Pigman and raccoon man
side by side the brothers and just made
that to look Sally I love that this was
insane and awesome what was a Jack Jack
blew it blew it but made yeah made a
whole comic The Adventures of cat man
I'm no hero to Sunnis like any other day
camping gambling farming meeting new
people shopping the classic things are
on a business it's so great the whole
story behind it all looks so good
seriously I did yourself Kermit the
Hedgehog did a nice one here I like the
mask choice it's like kind of an awkward
just like almost like sticking his
crotch out but not oh these are so good
this is from Nick Garrett he what I
noticed was like when I first saw it I
said wow I didn't know you can play as a
bear but what I what I liked didn't
notice I guess is that he has a bandana
on awesome or also also and like you can
not see his face so if you keep
scrolling through it quite literally it
just looks like a bear dual weed
wielding here so awesome well done and
then with one with the Sheep yeah one
with this family
it's from Phil Mikkey McGee that's just
like a good-looking arty man I know
right
I don't know about the beer the the
chinstrap beards a little a little
strange but I mean like it works in a
way yeah definitely works is fit now
they're going here oh this is the this
is from the same one with the green
lighting yes I saw that one too yeah it
kind of looks like the horse is [ __ ]
blood
yeah this is inkblot wolf Wanda the wolf
and yet I like that and this one it's
clearly lighting a cigar cigarette butt
looks like he's just dwelling on this
match this flame I feel no pain awesome
is that it that's it
awesome guys yeah whole bunch thank you
guys so much and as always send us your
artis hashtag show us your arty and
we'll see y'all next week thank you so
much take care bye bye
[Music]